you've been called The DaVinci of our
time what do you say to that
absolutely ridiculous I don't pain where
to Sir as to the hospital please happy
no Tony you know we have to be real
Hospital I don't have anything I see
activity for three months or two things
I want to do I want an American
cheeseburger and the other that's not
for that not what you think I want you
to call for press conference yeah call
for a press conference okay
dry for cheeseburger first lack of a
better option dummy is still on fire
safety if you'd ask me again and I'm not
on fire I'm donating you to a City
College er I loved you in A Christmas
Story by the way my name is Tony Stark
and I'm not afraid of you I know you're
a coward so I've decided that you just
died pal prone to self-destructive
tendencies I was dying I mean please and
aren't we all
textbook narcissism agreed you know the
question I get asked most often is Tony
how do you go to the bathroom soon just
like that yes for the moment I'm not
dying thank you
what do you mean you're not dying do you
just say you're dying don't you uh no
I'm not not anymore
what's what's going on I was going to
tell you I didn't want to you tell me
you really were dying you didn't let me
to tell me that I was gonna make you an
omelet and tell you I don't want to see
this under my space [ __ ] please no gang
signs
now throw it a pumpkin yeah peace I love
peas truth is I am Iron Man
you